موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامبرز
ان تسريب وثائق عسكريه امريكيه سريه امر
مؤسف للغايه لكنه لم يذكر تفاصيل بشان ما
وصفها بانها تحقيقات مكثفه للغايه من جانب
وزارتي الدفاع والعدل واضاف بنز انه عليه
ان يتعلم الدرس من ذلك بخصوص طريقه تجديد
اجراءاتنا كما قال
من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيين
بلاده تواصلت مع حلفائها وشركائها على
مستويات عاليه خلال الايام الماضيه بشان
الوثائق المسربه وطمانتهم بالتزامها
بحمايه معلوماتها الاستخباريه
من جهه قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي تاخذ
قضيه تسريب الوثائق السريه على محمل الجد
واضاف انه يعقد لقاءات يوميه مع قاده
عسكريين كبار لمتابعه القضيه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في مؤتمر
صحفي عقده مع نظير فلبيني ان هدف بلاده
والسلام والامن والاستقرار وخلق فرص وليس
الدخول في حرب بارده جديده والاحتواء
الصين وكانت الولايات المتحده والفلبين
بدات مناورات العسكريه تشمل تدريبات
بالذخيره الحيه لاول مره في بحر جنوب
الصين كما ستضم طائرات مروحيه عسكريه تهبط
على جزيره فلبينيه تبعد نحو 300 كيلومتر
من تايوان
قال وزير خارجيه تايوان لشبكه
وان بلاده مستعده للدفاع عن نفسها من جهه
اخرى قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه انها
رصدت 26 مقاتله وتسعه سفن حربيه صينيه في
محيط الجزيره رغم اعلان الصين اختتام
مناورات عسكريه تحاكي تطويقه تايوان
من جهتها قالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان قضيه
تايوان شان داخلي محض وان مبدا الصين
واحده محل اجماع من المجتمع الدولي مؤكده
ان الجزيره جزء لا يتجزا من اراضي الصين
قرر رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو وقف الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه
للمسجد الاقصى فيما تبقى من شهر رمضان
وقالت رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه ان
نتنياهو قرر منع دخول اليهود الى باحات
الاقصى حتى نهايه الشهر في حين هاجم وزير
الامن القومي اتمار بن جبير هذا القرار
وقال انه جاء بسبب موجه الارهاب ووصفه
بالخطا الفادح الذي سيؤدي الى مزيد من
التصعيد حسب تعبيره
اكدت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي مقتل فلسطينيين
اثنين برصاص الجيش عند مستوطنه الون موريا
المقامه على اراضي قريه دير الحطب شرقي
نابلس في الضفه الغربيه وادعى جيش
الاحتلال ان الشاهدين حاول اطلاق النار
صوب المستوطنه
كتاب الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]